let's talk about the health benefits of
cacao and
dark chocolate now cacao is the raw bean
that's then
fermented and processed into chocolate
okay but there are some serious health
benefits
to both of these items in fact six
billion pounds is consumed on a yearly
basis
it is loaded with some serious
phytonutrients
polyphenols and flavonols which is more
in quantity than
blueberries or acai berries now there's
a tiny bit of caffeine involved
but you have a good amount of
theobromine which is a stimulant so of
course if you're going to consume this
later in the day or before bed that may
keep you
up now i consume a little bit of
chocolate on a regular basis not too
much
but i always consume no sugar type
chocolate i always make sure that it's
organic because they do spray
different chemicals including using
glyphosate
i primarily use these two brands right
here there's other ones that you can get
as well but they're usually flavored
with
erythritol and monk fruit or stevia
so there's quite a variety that you can
choose from all right let's look at the
benefits of cacao and dark chocolate
there's some seriously amazing benefits
for the heart
decrease blood pressure because you're
getting increased nitric oxide
which actually helps the smooth muscle
of the arteries now the blood pressure
effect can also happen
due to the high levels of magnesium it's
also loaded with iron and potassium and
copper and phosphorus and
zinc number two it can increase your hdl
decrease your ldl especially the
oxidized ldl
number three major studies showing the
decrease
in risk of heart disease okay this
is the big one right here decreasing
endothelial
dysfunction this is where heart disease
starts it's the inside of the layer
of the artery specifically the coronary
that starts to become damaged and then
the cholesterol comes and the calcium
comes and builds up
plaquing and a clot and so
these antioxidants protect the inside
layer of the artery
of course if you consume chocolate
without the
sugar which is like you know sandpaper
on the arteries
all right number four decreasing
cortisol
and adrenaline this is why many times
people consume chocolate to reduce
stress
all right number five it may decrease
the risk of certain cancers
number six decreasing insulin improves
insulin resistance
okay number seven you can decrease the
risk of strokes
number eight it can elevate your mood
and bring someone
from a depressed state to a higher level
they don't know exactly why this is it
could be
because of the increase in serotonin it
because of the theobromine but it can
also be from the polyphenols
okay but regardless it seems to create a
cool effect
number nine it can increase your
physical performance
ten it can really help the skin's
circulation
probably because of this nitric oxide
right here
the texture of your skin the hydration
of your skin
and number eleven which is quite amazing
which relates to number three
it can decrease metabox syndrome which
is a combination of
improving your blood sugars cholesterol
and blood pressure
the only thing i want to mention about
cacao or chocolate
is that it does have higher amounts of
oxlets
and so if you're at risk for kidney
stones i would probably recommend not
consuming it
hey before you go real quick i have a
course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system
it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today